[Music]
[Applause]
hi Barbie hi
Barbie Barbie see Barbie Barbie hi
Barbie Barbie L Barbie
barie hi
Barbie
[Music]
guess what Bobby fans hi Barbie Bobby hi
Barbie in the summer of 2023 Barbie took
over Barbie Barbie Barbie the film was
inescapable but Barbie isn't the first
movie to do a massive summer
takeover it is as if God created the
devil and gave him Jaws jaws basically
invented the modern Blockbuster I guess
is the way to put it I'm Melissa
Wilkinson I'm a senior correspondent at
Vox and a Critic before Jaws no movie
had made $100 million at the box office
this didn't happen by accident it was
all a strategy that started long before
Jaws the movie and okay so I could talk
about Jaws for literal hours but in the
interest of time here are the
highlights from the bestselling novel
Jaws jaws was a book first which is true
of a lot of movies obviously and always
has been producers at Universal acquired
the film rights to Jaws Before Peter
benchley even got the book published
they started pouring money into the
book's marketing they got it into book
clubs designating it as book of the
month there was skywriting at beaches
that said read Jaws hype was built and
perhaps inevitably Jaws the novel became
a Blockbuster in its own right sitting
at the top of the bestsellers list for
44 weeks straight the intellectual
property was effectively
leveraged then just one year after the
book release the film came out and it
was good a giant shark beautiful
cinematography and an Innovative score
that kept you on the edge of your
seat it couldn't really be more
appealing when the studio showed it to
test audiences they realized they had a
massive hit on their hands and so they
started sinking money early into
marketing so I believe the number they
spent on marketing was somewhere in the
1.8 million range for about 11 million
in $
2023 that's not anything compared to the
amount that movies are marketed for now
but it was a lot at the time a large
chunk of that cash was spent on
television ads in the days before its
opening weekend they saturated the
market buying 30second spots on every
Prime Time television show on all the
major networks or at least the ones that
would let them which was about 80 to 85%
Time Magazine featured Jaws on its front
cover and for a while it seems like you
couldn't escape the film it's not just
the idea that you know the movie is
coming out but also that it's an event
you need to be part of and that you'll
be missing out if you don't take part in
it the main reason that say I don't know
like a Citizen Cane or 2001 Space
Odyssey are not considered Blockbusters
is in that time you would release a
movie in maybe like one or two cities
and then it would roll out slowly Jaws
didn't follow that strategy it opened in
409 theaters in the US and 55 more in
Canada on June 20th
1975 squarely in the middle of summer
which makes sense as Jaws was all about
warm weather in beaches but back then
big movies didn't often release in the
summer why would summer be a good time
you know you want to be outside where
it's nice and this is sort of pre-air
conditioning for a lot of people so
maybe it's very uncomfortable all these
factors the book promo the intense movie
promo the timing it all LED Jaws to
become the highest grossing movie ever
made at that point crossing the $100
million Mark just 61 days after its
release when something is successful in
Hollywood what we immediately see are
repeats over and over over derivations
copies but also just attempts to capture
lightning in a bottle again we have
Blockbusters every year since then that
are using essentially the Jaws formula
the Star Wars movies Indiana Jones
movies Mission Impossible movies all of
these different films really count as
Blockbusters in part because they
replicated that formula now A lot
changes between jaws and barie but when
you look at the overlying Blockbuster
strategy they're almost formulaically
identical they both leverage
pre-existing IP though with Barbie it's
much bigger than the Jaws thing you know
we're talking about Decades of toys
Decades of commercials they were both
released in the summer on every screen
possible and they both took Market
saturation to the extreme but what
separates Barbie from all the
Blockbusters that came before is that it
had a much steeper uphill battle there
has always been the perception among the
predominantly male executives of
Hollywood that women will go see a movie
starring a man but men won't go see
movie starring women and whether or not
that's a cultural product of just not
having movies starring women is a big
big question so making Barbie is
obviously a
gamble to mitigate that gamble the
Barbie team needed to act strategically
the first step was elevating the idea of
what a Barbie movie could be they
brought in someone with I would say a
defined Style style or at least a
defined idea of what kinds of stories
she tells Greta gerig has generally made
smaller thoughtful films about The Human
Condition making her an unconventional
choice for something of this scale it
sent the message that Hollywood wasn't
just making a Barbie cash grab movie the
movie would be more elevated and
subversive than you might expect I mean
the first trailer references The
Evolution of Man scene from 2001 A Space
Odyssey a movie that came out in 1968
that's like 3 hour is long and literally
about all of human life which is very
cool but also very film bro which I can
say because you know I mean look at
me that trailer was dropped before
Avatar the way of water a blockbuster
that was poised to be a big hit meaning
it would get maximum exposure but it's
not a typical pairing you know horror
movies usually have horror trailers
preceding them action movies have action
trailers to put Barbie before Avatar was
a clear signal that they were trying to
reach across to an audience that
wouldn't immediately be into
Barbie for a long time this is what
Barbie looked like but the movie and the
marketing took a different approach
representing more types of people and
allowing anybody to become Barbie either
by using the selfie generator or you can
make a Barbie figure of yourself you can
stand in the pink box and take a picture
and put it on Instagram you know I think
I'm the only person who hasn't done that
like in the world at this point you
could stay in Barbie's dreamhouse thanks
to Airbnb or watch your favorite
interior designers build a Barbie
Dreamhouse thanks to HGTV you could live
the Barbie lifestyle in the real world
this isn't something you can do with
other Blockbusters like you could buy
the flash of sneakers but one they never
wear those sneakers in the movie two
more importantly they don't really let
you embody the character fully but you
could be Barbie in one simple
way it's pink it's just pink so you
could walk around in Pink clothing and
it was a Barbie thing or there's a cafe
that popped up that was the Barbie cafe
it's hard to overstate the power of
Simplicity with brand tiin like I'd love
to be Spider-Man but finding something
with graphic design that I like is
challenging but you want a Barbie Burger
give it some pink ooze and you got
yourself a brand iion Barbie outfits
it's as easy as this according to Josh
goldsteen the head of marketing at WB it
stopped being a marketing campaign and
became a movement they didn't have to
reach out to every brand because every
brand wanted a bite of the Barbie
Apple can I talk about barbin Heimer now
please I mean barbin Heimer joke started
where it was like isn't it funny that
these two are coming out on the same day
and it is one is
dark it's just dark the other one is
pink thematically one is about death and
the other one is maybe also about death
you guys ever think about dying like
that would be weird and funny and then
people thought well wouldn't it be
funnier if you went and saw both movies
on the same day and the result of this I
think is that Barbie got a boost because
men who might have felt weird about just
buying a ticket for a Barbie movie now
they're going to see it as part of a
double feature so it's kind of a bit and
himer definitely got a boost from the
scene the marketing was a mix of
strategy luck and a bunch of tie-in and
it paid off the box office for Barbie
was definitely surprising in the way
that the box office for black panther
was considered surprising at the time
which was that they expected it to make
a lot of money they just didn't expect
it to make that much money that fast in
the theater Barbie crossed the billion
doll Mark in just 177 days at the Box
office only 53 movies have done that so
far and Barbie is the only one solely
directed by a woman according to variety
the Barbie marketing team spent an
estimated $150 million marketing the
movie against the production budget of
145 million meaning they spent more
money marketing the movie than they did
making it this isn't uncommon but
throwing money into marketing doesn't
always work out it might help your
opening weekend but keeping that
momentum going is often harder one thing
that's really unique about Barbie for
2023 anyhow is that people are going
back to see it multiple times and I
think it's because it it's sort of a
unique film in the Blockbuster World in
that it's kind of subversive it's got a
little bit of everything for a copile
but it's also very warm and very
warm-hearted like it's not a bummer of a
movie and it's funny to get to a billion
generally you need both things a good
movie movie and a great marketing
campaign in 2023 the year of Barbie
Warner Brothers was able to synthesize
them
both hey if you're still around thank
you so much for watching this video I
genuinely appreciate it like with all
our videos uh there is just so much to
put into every story and I couldn't fit
it all in but if you want to learn some
more I'm going to leave some interesting
podcasts in the description below which
were awesome and so fun and dove into
jaws and Barbie in ways that I just
couldn't in the making of this video uh
and while you're in the description you
might notice one other link box.com sgiv
now if you click it it'll take you here
to a web page where you can make a
contribution to keep Fox's journalism
free we here at Vox are big Believers
that information should be free for
everyone which is why this video is here
on YouTube and not locked behind a pay
wall somewhere but if you wanted to
support voxa journalism the best way to
do that is by becoming a contributor as
a special thank you to those who make
recurring contributions you'll get
access to behind the scenes tutorials
and Q&A with Fox journalists from across
the entire Newsroom and I think this is
an important thing to stress because uh
donations wouldn't just go to these fun
movie videos that go to coverage of
really important topics like the
upcoming 2024 election for instance the
goal right now is 85,000 total
contributions by the end of 2023 to keep
on Pace for that we need to add 2 ,500
contributions this month now we know
that not everyone is in a place where
they can support us so if you can't
that's totally fine feel free to give us
a thumbs up because that's free and goes
a really long way but if you do have the
means to contribute head over to vox.com
give now and consider making a
contribution